grace is with us in Dallas Texas
hi grace welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
I game how are you better than I deserve
what's up well I wanted to thank you for
taking my call and our pastor started
this year off with message broke is
normal be weird and it brought me to
your book
I've told Money Makeover which I've just
finished reading on Friday so much and
yeah and it was amazing if I felt like
you are giving me power to take control
and I'm sorry I'm so emotional okay so
we're trying to get everything in order
I've been using everyday dollars since
October mm-hmm and that was
life-changing to see the reality of your
situation and so we were looking at our
debt and when I finished reading the
book you had that last testimonial where
tomorrow's I think it talked about how
they sold their house because they had
the equity to pay off the all their debt
and we are we have that same situation
so we were thinking is it wise to sell a
house to sell your house and pay off
your debt and still have money left over
and and so that you can move through the
steps faster and have that burden lifted
off okay so now you're in so much debt
do you have not killing your house 64000
okay and what is your household income
it's about a hundred years net a month
we're getting sixty five hundred and our
expenses are about fifty five hundred
and but that's including our tithing
yeah and so you still have 401k or
something coming out of your check other
than taxes
yeah my husband doesn't isn't sure if
he's able to stop that he works for the
city of Fort Worth as an officer and I
just stopped mine last week while I was
reading the book you said to do that so
I went on television yeah zero well he
may have he may have a mandatory
withdrawal or a mandatory retirement
contribution but he needs to find out
what is what the deal is because you're
not getting home with nearly enough
money how much was your tax refund last
year it was about oh I think it was
almost ten thousand okay yeah I was
thinking that we were going to hear
something like that because see a
hundred thousand eighty three hundred a
month to get down to sixty five hundred
is two thousand dollars a month coming
out that's wrong okay now some of that
was going to retirement and some of that
is going to retirement so we need to
find out about the retirement and then
you need to get with a tax professional
and determine what your proper
withholding is and a gesture withholding
because you don't want to have big tax
refunds that's just allowing the
government money tax-free or interest
free all year long now
and your home is worth what or whom we
spoke to a realtor yesterday who said
that we would probably get anywhere
between 285 and 295 and what do we owe
94 okay all right do you like your home
it's not our dream home do you like your
home yes okay we like our home how long
have you lived there eight years and
your children are held we have a 10 11
13 and 16 year old okay and so they're
all in the school system associated with
this home yeah so moving is a traumatic
thing for you guys yeah that's why the
emotion right yeah and we I mean we even
actually it chokes you up thinking about
it it does because I mean my mother
passed away two years ago and I even
planted a tree out front her you know
yeah yeah do not sell your home
okay you don't need to sell your home
it's going to take you between two and
three years to get this debt cleared how
much of the sixty-four thousand s car
payments 34 34 and what is the most
expensive car
it's the minivan that's the one that's
causing me issues in my head well
Michael what's the most expensive car
how much this way we owe 24 350 24 of 64
is one car that's what I would sell when
I looked at Blue Book because I looked
at selling it I even called the loan
company bank and she they said that the
Blue Book it's valuing the car of
minivan at 15,000 and so I was like if I
said oh that's alright that's a banker
giving you a banker answer you need to
go to Kelly Blue Book and look at
private sale that minivan is probably
worth 19 and if you sold it to an
individual which leaves you 5 in the
hole and if you had to borrow that 5 I'd
rather you be $5,000 in debt than
$24,000 in debt oh by the way we're
going to keep your house with the tree
in the front yard that you planted all
right we're getting rid of your stupid
minivan the second thing you don't do is
you and your husband I sit down and
finish see what's happened here is you
are completely dialed in on how
important this is but you're just now
learning the tactics the things to do
you've got the emotion and the passion
but now you're learning what to do at
this moment I sense he's gotten either
he's gotten on board this weekend
because we really sat down and spent
many hours talking about our oceans and
he's cracked the book open ok good so
it's just starting it's just not so okay
I'm not saying he was I'm not saying he
was pushing back but I knew he wasn't
there yet yeah so we're just getting
involved and so no you do not need to
sell your house yes you need to get on a
scorched-earth budget no eating out
unless you don't even need to be
inside of a restaurant les you're
working there it's a job okay and no
vacations and no nothing and the answer
the kids get to every question is no
we're keeping our house no we're selling
the minivan no we're gonna be out of
debt in two years we're not gonna have
any payments but a house payment how's
that gonna feel so good you can do that
in two years when you sell this stupid
minivan this is gonna work for you okay
now have you guys gotten signed up for
Financial Peace University yet no we
will be you are now you're going as my
guest
thank you all right I'm gonna pay for it
and you guys go in there you are ripe
for the picking you're going to do this
stuff you and your husband both you're
open you're ready to learn when the
student is ready the teacher just
appeared and I'm going to show you
exactly what to do and you're gonna
score touchdown after touchdown after
touchdown like you're in the dadgum
Super Bowl I'm so proud of where you're
going to be already in two years I can
see it so clearly when you're willing to
do anything to win and you called me up
being willing to sell your house you're
willing to do anything when you're ready
to do that you're ready to win people
who want to ish stuff are the ones that
don't win you're ready you're sick and
tired of being sick and tired and when
you get there that's when you change
your life you have officially said I've
had it and when you get there I can help
you won't on kellyo pickup we'll get you
guys signed up for the nine week class
Financial Peace University we're also
when you sign up for that these days we
throw in a year membership to the online
experience of financial peace which is
all the classes all the online every
dollar plus is included all of that is
my gift to you and you call me back and
tell me how you're doing and if you got
any questions or you get scared while
you're working out you call me when you
get your debt free you call me we're
here to help you